pin hello and welcome to this video
playing donkey shot that don't kiss hot
Monica shot him all right let's see what
happens in this game this video will be
uploaded basically right after it is
played so going to be almost like a
livestream in in a way on Friday April
12
okay so i'ma taking the b7 pawn
see what donkey shot is doing
ciao Queen b6 is the best move him
Quincy age is an alternative but it is
not
not so good no black should probably
trade yeah I did
yeah White has one main adium b4 b5 this
is an interesting move but I can reply
rather quickly
it is helpful if you have looked at
stuff beforehand
[Music]
but you can piece together this
information a little bit if you watch
the video and know what I'm currently
working on
yeah 97 is not such a great idea
to go 95 now
you take the really long time I mean I'd
be five is completely forced so um yeah
here I could probably take
and rugae five
an interesting an interesting point that
I just realized is that a pasta possible
be six move I cannot take so I should
probably castle there was Bishop before
then
you
yeah okay this is I think easily
answered with c6 and now I guess rook a
one getting a six back and after orders
the c6 pawn will be weak and he has no
development which is something that at
the very beginning it's not so obvious
that this is a problem but it definitely
is okay this is a good move this good
move he wants to force my bishop to a
bad diagonal so that night night p8
becomes possible
it's a very ugly move but still possible
a cave ago Bishop e5 for the Templars f6
and Bishop c7 he has rook a7
yeah that's interesting
I mean I'm not really worried here all
that much might be a drug see one I will
probably get this pawn back anyway
well let's say it's um his concessions
that he has to make us so severe the dam
not really worried so much but I think I
probably didn't play it in the best
possible way that it's very likely
so f6 maybe now or you know f6
what am I going to do I guess this one
and then f3 @e 493 bishop before and so
on it's very difficult for black to to
get into
play we can actually realize this
material advantage even though I'd
certainly certainly missed something
yeah I'm very sure about that maybe the
the timing wasn't quite right which is
often a problem you kind of know that
you have to play in a certain way I knew
that I have to place his six for example
in such a position and break this up but
I wasn't expecting this defense by black
and it is it is good yeah he defended as
well really I mean it's not a bad player
of wisdom
okay now I can yeah it's interesting
play this him I cannot play five I mean
I mean I can but I'm not sure if I
should
Jake
a tick King takes 95 I mean yes he has a
5 then which is kind of annoying really
you know they have excellent strategic
compensation I mean he cannot move the
pawns and everything but is it is it
really something that I can play for win
is something no Here I am hmm what do I
do now it's kind of tricky f4 or a go F
form let's do this I mean it's Bishop is
kind of abysmal them but a kid can come
out
look everyone I guess or rugge f6 I
still have pretty strong pressure
and this absolutely it's not obvious how
is ever going to use the a or C pawn
mmm YUM for guru
I should probably win back upon if
possible
so this one and now going to switch over
to the other side everyone
look f1 threatening yeah I don't think
he can play a five it shouldn't be
possible really
now aged four maybe fixing that on a
light square but DG Ponder's some is
upon it I can maybe win at some point
[Music]
with this one kind of unsure here what's
best
fixing even more on light squares now on
a five is under under a down okay
you know I mean he has a hard time too
with this stuff but
I is defending this extremely well
I think
no now he has an issue there
with the bishop movement
yeah I mean um that's something that has
to be checked first of all I didn't
convert this like this is winning
already I know I know that when I
analyzed that this is basically almost
winning at least so something went wrong
there Ruka a 5 not going to tell you the
in the details about the first moves
because I mean there's something yeah
you can piece it together I guess so
let's have a look here a 6mm castles
didn't know anything beyond this rugae
five a-six I didn't remember let's say
here maybe there's a matter here here's
very maybe where I need to be more
accurate
I went c6 which Luke c1 is better okay
so let's let's check this so the thing
is if I manage to place his six and I
get this kind of thing I'm winning a six
and B five then is also basically gone
so it is a very very narrow path for
black so it seems that g5 is okay here
okay
at least that's what the engine is
showing so what does it what is the line
we should be to and now I would be
worried about Knight should be eight but
probably this is not a very
if six is what the engine wants to play
so night b8 what is the thing I know I
can play here and then this is gone yeah
that's a very important idea that I did
not that I wasn't aware of now he cannot
prevent who takes b5 I was always
worried that he would play night ba to
c6 but that never works really
so f6 and then I get c6 and takes rook
takes and this looks really awful but
the engine does not really condemn it
all that much for black maybe I don't
have a good square for marroquin c6 so
we could be six king deservin
and now I mean I can actually win that
pawn but knight c6 seems to hoard so
currently the engine Caesar pill sees an
interesting defense there so I probably
maybe I confused something I thought
that this is already basically gone for
black but it doesn't seem to be so
terrible it's a bit tricky to remember
the intricacies here because there are
lines like that there are some quite
similar lines let's say it's what I'm
trying to say
maybe I confused something anyway I've
lit c6 which I don't think it's that
terrible actually because it really I
mean black has to stay very passive them
with this night be aid so I don't really
think I'm in a huge trouble here
I have enough compensation um
rooks c1 yeah probably many ideas that
you can you can look at 91 yeah the
engine is getting kind of skeptical here
does not
show that I have enough compensation
look h7 what is supposed to be better
here like H 5 H 5 f 3 king f7 Assessor
is a line I mean there are certainly
many more possibilities I would have
probably tried the same thing as in the
game this kind of thing but then B
should be 6 yeah and then I would the
table should be form and then Bishop c7
yeah this is a very important important
idea he has to keep this Bishop and that
makes a whole lot of difference if I get
to trade this like in a position like
this this is not such a problem because
I mean he cannot move anything
and there are even scenarios where being
a pawn down I'm very okay yeah that it's
probably more precise and here he had
the opportunity to play c5 okay I don't
quite see how that is possible so I take
and a 96 maybe I am he has this idea
okay yeah that was a huge huge
opportunity for black you know and it
here I felt I should be really okay oh
yeah the engine it says is this is equal
which or even studied better for a while
yeah that was my feeling as well if
anybody can do something it's rather
white because I mean how do you ever
activate blacks position not here I'm
better right you know I probably missed
something something here you should f1
the immediately should be grouping is
stronger than moving the rook around but
the engine thinks I'm better here
rook age 7 and then Bishop f1 d3 edits
stronger hi I was thinking that it made
sense to provoke this pawn for but it's
very slow and I think at least that is
my hunch that here the black should have
equality is kind of what I thought like
he can probably not win with
spawn which I'm also not able to him to
make any progress and now we had to play
King AIDS to be in time to move the
bishop it's possible that that that
could be already problematic here rook a
one king - and now King e8 leads to
trouble he has to find root D one man
which makes a lot of sense preventing
Bishop d3
and then I have to do something b3r ooga
- and it seems to be just about a draw
and this is no problem right but b3 is
still working that it's interesting why
right I am Kim he keeps on da okay he
stays on the F oh yeah that makes a lot
of sense so that you can do this now if
I take played Bishop g6 he has this move
and this is of course okay I have this
one so I'm getting a pawn back but
that's probably going to be a draw you
know and this this is just blundered it
away it's not so easy I mean black was
under some pressure of the game I have
to check the Sun I have to check this
line again in my analysis because this
is kind of
yeah that is not great maybe I have
something better here actually that
isn't that is another point really like
if you take
I mean what I'm trying to say is
unsuccessfully is you can make an
argument for castling in this position
keeps this option open and just ask
black about the next move which does not
necessarily need to be a six but after
take taegeuk ff8 a six and if you place
a six for example I could think about
taking and now not going to a five but
to a one or whatever some some options
there yeah okay guys thanks for watching